hello everyone and welcome to the final
game uh which is game five of the first
day of the opera euro rapid tournament
it's linear dominguez versus magnus
carlson
and dominguez so far hasn't won a game
but he did get two draws and magnus is
still on a killing spree he lost the
first game to wesley so and then he won
three games and
uh this is game five so let's see what
happens here as this is a really crazy
game so hope you guys enjoy it
uh let's check it out dominguez with the
white pieces uh opens
with e4 uh we have a c5 magnus that goes
for his sicilian as he usually does
knight to f3 d6 and now d4
so a nice open sicilian we have captures
captures in the knight to f6 we have
knights to c3
and now magnus does not go for the night
of but rather he goes
g6 he goes for the dragon variation of
the sicilian
which is extremely extremely sharp so
here that bishop to e3
going after some normal development with
moves like f3
g4 h4 h5 and so on everything you play
against the dragon queen d2 castle
queenside king b1
and so on so uh bishop to g7 and now
f3 uh we have a6 by magnus this is a
not an extremely rare move but it is
somewhat rare uh knight to c6 is uh
usually played here
or castles even more uh but okay magnus
goes for a6 and now
queen to d2 you always want to have this
setup going after that dark square
bishop
so h5 and now he develops the bishop to
c4 so bishop to c4
and now knight b to d7 so this has all
been seen before
and interestingly last year uh alexander
grisham had this position against magnus
carlsen uh in the saint louis rapid
tournament and grishop won this by
playing bishop to b3 here
it was a pretty pretty fun game i i
think we actually showed it
but here instead of bishop to b3 we have
queen side castles
uh by dominguez and now magnus just
continues developing on the queen side
with b5 bishop to b3
and now there are some games where uh
bishop to b7 and knights the e5 were
played but here
we have knight to c5 and it is as of
movie 11 that we have a completely new
game
so let's see what happens here king to
b1 a nice prophylactic move by dominguez
uh and now bishop to b7 so just putting
pieces on optimal squares the rook is
coming to c8 and so on
rook h2e1 and now rook to c8 by magnus
and here
you have to figure out how to continue
mounting the pressure do you want to
play something like a3 h3 maybe knight
to d5 or as was played in the game
dominguez goes for
bishop to g5 uh so uh it's putting
putting a lot of pressure on the
position as e5 is is coming
and you wanna put some pressure towards
that e7 pawn so here magnus castled
and now comes knight to d5 so now
offering some traits here
and the capturing doesn't really do
anything because like we said there's
going to be a lot of
weak pawns here uh specifically the e71
for example if bishop captures attacks
the bishop
and let's say you capture now there's a
problem of this pawn hanging and you
can't really
do anything to defend that if you go
rook eight knight c6
attacks the queen and triples the attack
on the pawn uh
this is going to be a terrible game for
for black so instead after knight b5
magnus kicks the way it kicks away the
knight with
e6 we have knight captures with czech
bishop captures in the now uh first h4
the idea is uh dominguez wants magnus to
capture so he can play g4 and bust open
uh carlsen's king side so magnus says
sure no problem
bishop captures we have h captures and
king to g7
as magnus is expecting the h file to
open up he wants to have this uh
possibility of playing rook to h8 and
here while you could play
g4 here it would be maybe a bit too soon
because after h captures on g4 and rook
to h1
you can easily play rook to h8 so
opening up the
the h file right now doesn't really do
all that much here you could
trade everything captures captures and
even go
knight captures on e6 with check but
even though i think uh
dominguez definitely checked this it
doesn't yield more than a draw for him
for example knight
captures bishop captures an e6f capture
so now queen captures and d6 black is up
a piece but
that black king is uh well looking
terrible there so
maybe dominguez considered this maybe
not but it will be hard to
uh to win this so instead he played
queen to e3
and now queen to c7 by magnus at some
point you want to eliminate this bishop
and you will have some threats here
on the c2 pawn for a moment it is very
nicely defended by the bishop and
the knight so rook to d2 dominguez uh
adds another defender to the c2 pawn and
now b4 by
magnus we have rook e to d1 doubles up
rooks on the d
file and now comes rook f to d8 so
defending that pawn
we have queen to f4 by magnus with ideas
of queen to f6
by dominguez with ideas of queen to f6
check and magnus defends with queen to
e7
and now we have knight to e2 and this is
already a very interesting position
because
magnus most definitely has to play
e5 here he cannot allow white to play e5
and after
you push back the queen for example
queen e3 then you continue with
a5 uh uh kind of try and trap the bishop
with a4 and so on
and black's position will be amazing
here however magnus played a5 right away
and now dominguez seizes the opportunity
and pushes e5 and now there's a problem
there's always this queen to f6
check and uh that white white pawn on f6
will be simply amazing
so magnus doesn't want to open lines he
plays d5 and
now comes g4 this was actually a very
very uh sneaky position as well because
here
a4 is coming and this could trap your
bishop but there was bishop to c4 in the
position
where you're just preparing to shift the
bishop to the d3 basically here
uh the problem is the bishop cannot be
captured if you capture the bishop then
you have this
very annoying rook captures rook
captures and queen f6
check and then white just the white just
wins queen captures you're going to
capture back with
check king h7 and rook capture 78 you're
up the exchange in a better position
uh black's pieces are terrible here it
would be an easy win
uh of course uh it's not it's not a
force line but bishop to c4
definitely the way to go here however
dominguez goes for g4
he wants to attack on the king side now
h captures on g4 and now he goes for
queen to f6 with check magnus
has to trade otherwise just queen
captures or you could even blunder you
if you defend the queen then just queen
to h8 is checkmate
so magnus has to trade here we have
queen captures on f6 and now
g captures on f6 this comes with check
and here
king to h6 and the problem is um
this is a this is a an incredibly tricky
position where
uh white is actually completely winning
but it's
not an easy move to find so both of them
missed it during the game
but you're you know enjoying yourselves
at your homes
so feel free to pause the video and try
to find the winning move for dominguez
here while i give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on finding the
only
and uh might i say extremely difficult
move that wins in this position
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's but
no it's not that it's rook to d4
rook to d4 with the idea that after rook
to h1 check comes king goes
to g5 then rook captures and g4 is game
over
but it's easier said than done because
figuring out this move is is just crazy
for example
if you capture an f3 threat on the
knight then you still go
rook to g4 you simply prevent the king
from reaching the square and the king
cannot go back to f6 and now there's not
much you can do
whatever you're getting checkmated so
let's just uh checkmate
the black king right away and if you
don't do something like this after rook
the d4 you might play something like g5
to free the g6 square for your king
uh it doesn't really do you all that
much rook captures on g4
and now just rook h1 check is coming you
can double up on the g
file for example king g6 just redeed the
g1 now
and there isn't anything you can do here
if rook to h8 you're just gonna capture
on g5 with check
king h6 and now rook somewhere let's say
rook to
rook to g3 and then you will deliver
checkmate with rook to h1 or rook to h3
it doesn't really matter uh but yeah
after this king to h6 move rook to d4
was deadly however both of them missed
it and a rook the h1 check was played
right away
and although it seems like it's the same
idea why not just play rook and
rook to d4 on the next move it doesn't
work uh magnus plays king to g5
and here we have f4 with check if you go
rook to d4
uh now just g captures on f3 and there's
no
good move here for you to play you're no
longer threatening rook to g4
and if you deliver king king to g1 king
the f5 is coming and then king captures
here king captures here everything falls
apart for white
so instead dominguez played f4 with
check he forced the king to f5
only move for magnus and now rook to f1
defending the pawn and threatening some
very nasty knights the g3
checkmate so magnus has to make some
room for the king uh
and he plays g5 g3 was also possible but
it looks too dangerous
so here knights to d4 with check and now
king to g6 king that e4 is actually even
stronger for magnus and it is in fact
winning
looks super scary but there's nothing
white can do here uh because
if you move this then this falls if you
move this rook then this falls and then
everything falls
and other than that there's just not not
all that much for you to do
so instead king to g6 was played by
magnus and
now comes f5 with check busting open the
f file
e captures and now knight captures on f5
again with the terrible threat of knight
to e7 for example
if black isn't careful if you if you
play something like rook to h8
just knight e7 check and where can the
black king go to only to the h file and
wherever you go along the h file it's
just going to be a nice checkmate
because the pawn covers this square
and the knight covers these squares and
it's checked so of course it's checkmate
so magnus really hanging on by a thread
here magnus finds
uh the only move that doesn't lose and
that's g3
uh he has to make some some room for his
king uh so after king to h5 he can
access the g4 square
and now knight the knight to e7 check
isn't all that impressive because king
h5 and even if you capture the rook
uh doesn't really do anything knight
captures on b3 threatens to pick up the
rook with check so a captures rook
captures
and we get to this um end game where
magnus is down the exchange but he has a
pretty impressive pawn on g3
so not not really something you can
easily
dispose off so instead after this g3
we have rook to g2 by dominguez going
after
the pawn now while the knight is nicely
defended he wants the bust open here
on the g file but now knight the e4 by
magnus guarding the pawn
so knight captures on g3 grabbing the
pawn now
and now rook to e8 again the the
absolute best move you have to get rid
of the spawns as these pawns are just
too strong so here knight captures we
have d captures on e4
and now even e6 here dominguez creates a
beautiful past f pawn
f captures and now f7 threatening
carlsen's rook rook to e8 and
now bishop captures uh on e6 uh so what
do you do here
uh rook the c5 magnus adds another
defender to the g5 pawn
and he says i'm slowly going to play
this rook over here and start pushing my
own pass pawn
uh and there's really no good way for
you to continue mounting pressure
because my pawn is on a dark square even
though
even though you can double rooks here my
king and rook will defend it nicely
and you don't have a dark square bishop
you have a light square bishop so you're
not breaking through here
so here rook to g3 and now
rook to e5 preparing to push that pawn
and here comes
bishop to g4 and here dominguez was
under
a lot of time pressure for a lot of
moves here it's already moved 41 but
dominguez is constantly under 10 seconds
uh playing an increment whereas magnus
has some two and a half minutes
so here bishop to g4 and now comes e3
magnus starts pushing his pass pawn king
to c1 dominguez starts bringing the king
into the game and now
uh finally rook captures on f7 uh rook
captures king captures and now
king to d1 the king will try and help
out with the blockade we have king to f6
and now
king to e1 with bishop to d5
magnus goes after the a2 pawn here and
now a3
we have captures captures and now bishop
to e4
going after the c2 pawn but allowing
this rook captures an e3 and here magnus
says
i'm very comfortable playing this end
game
with the bishops of the same color being
only up one pawn so here
uh rook captures on e3 we have bishop
captures on c2 and
now king to d2 magnus traits here
captures captures and now we enter this
end game
and you can see uh how how uh the
players play this king to e5
magnus improves the position of the king
bishop to f3
so you want to cut off the king from
reaching uh that pawn
on on on the queen side and it's not
it's not going to be all that
easy because the bishop covers these two
squares and also these squares are
covered so not a lot of squares for the
black king to use
so here we have bishop to f5 uh sorry
uh that i i accidentally showed you the
squares
the dark square bishop controls the
light square bishop controls these
squares the king covers this
and it's not easy for the black king to
reach that a3 pawn
so here bishop back to f5 and
now bishop to c6 we have king to d6
going after the pawn here and now bishop
back to f3 saying that
uh you will not have a lot of fun
approaching that pawn king to c5 and now
bishop to e2 again creating a wall
against
the black king so the black king cannot
approach this pawn here we have
bishop to g6 and now bishop to f1
just playing a waiting game checking to
see what magnus will do bishop to h5
and now king to e4 we have bishop to d1
and now comes king to e3 we have g4 by
magnus
and now bishop to a6 so just keeping
the the black king away from these
squares uh but now comes
bishop to f3 so bishop back to f1
and now bishop to c6 so we we will try
to counter this bishop like this
uh but we have king to f for going after
the pawn and now
uh here magnus played something very
interesting magnus played
king to d4 here he could have gone from
bishop to b5 which
kinda i think was the plan all along and
if bishop moves then we go bishop to d7
defend the pawn and then we try to
go over to this pawn it's bishop to f1
then king to d4 so
it kind of gets us closer and closer to
this pawn without
actually giving up this pawn but magnus
decided that it's not a problem we can
just give up this pawn he played king to
d4
king captures on g4 and now king to c3
we have king to f5 now king to b2
and here we have king to e5 going after
uh going uh uh closer to the queen side
and interestingly
uh the engines uh the engines give a
king to e5 as the losing move whereas
they give king for as as a not a losing
move but
uh this is something to too deep to
understand you'd have to
like uh really really go over this so if
any of you can figure out why
this is not losing and why this is
losing uh do sure in the comments and
i'm gonna uh
you know pin it for for everyone to see
so here king the e5
and now king captures on a3 now the
position is very very dangerous
king to d6 and now bishop to e8
so now the pass pawn just needs to be
promoted and every any
uh all that magnus has to take care of
is that
this bishop does not sacrifice itself
for the pawn when it touches the light
square if he can do that then it's a win
if not then it's a draw
uh due to insufficient material so here
king to c5 and now
a4 uh very dangerous because uh well
uh if the bishop somehow gets a hold of
this pawn it's all over but
it will require a few more moves bishop
to c4 we have
king to b2 we have king to b4 going
after the pawn
a3 now and now of course you cannot
reach the a2 square but
magnus has a plan he needs to shift this
bishop all the way here and then kick
away this bishop
and then somehow get this bishop again
this pawn to the a2 square without the
white
light square bishop covering it so
bishop d5 we have bishop to g6
uh bishop to e6 white uh has nothing to
do white simply has to wait
bishop to b1 we have bishop to d5
now comes bishop to a2 uh bishop to e4
and now bishop to f7 so now a2 is being
threatened if a2 comes then a1 wins the
game so
bishop to b sorry bishop to b1 uh
saying that okay what do you play here
uh if you push the pawn i'm just gonna
capture it
and of course if you capture this then
we're gonna capture on a3 and then again
it's a draw by insufficient material
so here uh feel free to pause the video
and try to find
the quickest winning idea for magnus
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on finding the
absolute quickest way to win
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's bishop to b3
and with the bishop on b3 bishop the c2
is coming then you trap the light square
bishop and then it's just game over
so it was in this position on move 72
that linear dominguez resigned the game
and magnus continues his killing spree
this is his fourth win in a row after
losing the
first game to wesley so so really really
impressive streak and
after the first day it's magnus who is
leading the tournament but we're not
going to check out the standings
tomorrow morning i'm going to show some
other games
as today we've only covered magnus so
we're going to
check out on some other games so don't
forget to use hashtag suggestion
uh to help me look for the the absolute
best of games
so here we resign because whatever you
do you simply either lose the bishop now
after bishop to c2 is played and then
the pawn promotes or you move the bishop
doesn't really matter where
now a2 and then a1 promotes to a queen
and wins the game uh so yeah
after uh bishop to b3 uh dominguez
resigned and
an excellent victory for magnus carlsen
uh so uh that's uh the game hope you
guys enjoyed it sorry about so many
uploads today but
this uh you know is rapid chess so we we
need to cover
plenty of games uh i would like to thank
the wall street cat
steven juani uh william right out eva
schatz
and dan miller for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank all for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this
wonderful tournament checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens
in the chess world uh so thank you all i
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day